olá bom dia é uma heroína e como diz e
maria é tolstoi cozinha enquanto futuro
economista é minha família torce pro
mundo e das coisas é com no g 4 e fica
tudo é ver sempre o saldo das coisas na
vida e por isso é 50 maior para o johnny
depp que nós temos hoje em dia tudo
estava acho que a missão básica que é a
maneira mais econômica derrubou um
problema é é atuar na prevenção é
invento área nas causas ano e vestuários
nas consequências e nas futuras possam
ser feitas para evitar e para dar a
volta à situação
e é por isso que eu acho que nós podemos
fazer muito para atuar na prevenção e na
diminuição do gênero épico
não vou tirar o valor ea estrutura de
hockey mas que hoje em dia as empresas
está tem feito para atuar no sentido de
entender mas mesmo na liderança é vir
mais raparigas é que também estão é
assumir posições com voz no futuro e vou
falar que nós aqui vocês podem fazer eu
vou dizer duas idéias orientou a
primeira é que eu acho que há dois tipos
de pessoas no mundo
ontem pessoas que são os que se de uma
óptima dança e depois quando ora justo
um salto em profundidade mas foi mais
cabeça ou não e quando chegarem saiba
teve frieza fria mas já estou
interessado vai passar outro de pessoas
que foram limpar piscinas vinho tinto e
turan profundidade
já pedi a digestão eu ia perguntar com
manuais qual é que você acha que será o
grupo pessoas destas duas que têm mais
propensão para ter sucesso na vida da
pessoa
na piscina o observa que a temperatura
estão afundados
a maioria é o grupo na piscina
o que preocupa não é o que vocês acham
curar seu grupo que tem mais sucesso é
que este grupo
na europa e china hoje em dia é um boys
cubo e uma escola porque nós desde
pequeno já é assim que o sinal de e
sempre nosso esporte foram e assim nós
também somos e seremos capazes assim
curiosos ganharem escondida já tenho uma
cicatriz e por outro lado de estrelas
como brigas que é bom ser bonita é bom
ter muito bom de tudo é bom ter 100%
perfeição ou vergonha eo por exemplo
como defenderia é pedir atenção quando
era pequena e norte com tomadores o auge
da sua vida é no final do ano e do
campeonato nacional e nós nos tanquinhos
três pistas de um lado os mais rápidos e
de outros mais lentos em cada pista
também estamos organizados como a última
heróis mais rápido e os últimos anos mas
antes estava emprestado mas não tem nome
e estava em segundo lugar e nós teremos
nunca mais que ter que estar nos seus
motores e quero muito ver uns 100 metros
não se está aqui alguém pratica natação
mas quando estamos a fazer tarefas mais
exigentes
temos um esquema que saída por exemplo
aqui nos segmentos ao menos de 20
ou seja se eu fizer 100 metros no minute
vez tem de ser um descanso para curtir o
assunto se eu fizer sem medo de meu
filho tem só dois pontos
então porque já enfrentei o joão ter um
colega meu empreendedor também o fim
sempre fizemos também não tava cansado
do que descansar mas não é
é então na segunda vez de ultrapassar o
skype
o jogo voltou a curtir o trecho à frente
e eu vou ter outra pessoal
o treinador disse que ainda vai pra
frente eles não não vai ter uma conta
força ainda mas eu não sei se consigo os
próximos e vou te fazer o pessoal deu
disse que a mãe não vai para frente ou
então eu achei da piscina e um não à
cabeça esta teria feito pois imagine uma
taxa nesse time e temos de provar a
ninguém que não fez o tempo de emissão
que é piloto e quando acabei a prova
nós temos aí diários em uma parte disso
é a taxa da manhã e quando eu saí do
treino da prova material de ensino
eu aceito isso fazer por todos instantes
tentar eu venho todo dia já não se
sustentar
eu fui para casa pensar
eu tenho razão e no treino não tinha
tido a coragem uma na frança eu tenho
até vergonha de ver e outra que saiu
depois já estava ruim e eu queria
ultrapassar perfeição ou nada e gorro
estar a ser realista e dizer que este é
o problema hoje em dia as raparigas mas
é o que tenho observado com alguma
consistência na minha vida
por exemplo eu dava explicações de uma
rapariga em institucionalizada onde é
performance dessas crianças é um pouco
mais baixa do que o normal
ela só uma rapariga era completamente
focado nela seria tudo e mais alguma
coisa das dificuldades dela e eu vi foi
uma situação qualquer e disse não
conhecer o fato é explicado que não era
uma rapariga e um rapaz de domingo
novamente fazer essa compreensão e um de
texto e matemática que é a cadeira e eu
mandei um trabalho de casa mais gente
era um teste de matemática e é um pouco
mais exigente na explicação cento quando
voltar voltar então mostrar como é que
foi
eu tinha feito eu não primeira reação
então não pode tentar não quero ter boa
nota e fui ver e eu tenha feito entre o
quarto irmão e algumas funções ea
alcunha tentado mas não estava certo e
não ter vergonha de 71 e ser tomada do
burro ou o que fosse mais uma vez o é
boa ou não era nada e só tinha dois
complicados e não por lutarem chapman
como é que nós podemos dizer que uma
professora
hoje em dia com turmas com 30 alunos
possam ver isto possa notar isto tem
parte da campanha dos times nas
categorias cinco jogos levantar essa
elas conseguem elas conseguem adaptar o
salto e uma professora na última 30 onde
não consegue ver isto como é com o
country manager de uma empresa consegue
ver são os homens comentou bros quando
crescer por um vídeo em junho estou a
pensar que não está em minhas críticas
todas e pensei que olhamos hoje em dia
próximo seguinte e preocupando não temos
mulheres à frente do do possível não
temos fins preocupante mas que tem
futuro
quem está não foi fácil não foi não é
fácil ver a vida daquelas pessoas e por
isso eu ia explodir
não há professor ensine as vossas filhas
com seis primeiras figurinhas há cinco
jogos
é difícil linda sempre é fácil mas ela
consegue no entanto sejamos honestos
estaria a ser um pouco injusta se
dissesse que o problema basicamente
treinos serem com jogos a outra face da
moeda é só falar com 11 oc6 já não é
consultora e tanto o jn trabalho
provável no rio que a mentalidade
equipas de alta performance e euzinha em
outro dia tem uma reunião é minha filha
ficou doente e eu tive que ir embora ea
primeira pergunta que fizeram fui então
campeão mineiro e está o problema
ou seja o mesmo instrumento estão até
vergonha de dizer que têm um papel igual
nos filmes do que as mulheres
eu acho que nós temos que estimular os
nossos rapazes não só para eles e para
os jogos mas temos nossos rapazes serem
a ter um papel importante na família
cria então papel importante na família a
minha magistrada e tem quatro filhos
nós vamos treinar e não sei se sabem
como funciona o processo por exemplo um
vídeo às vezes implicam deslocações e
quando a minha mãe poderia estar a ser
promovida a vizinha sempre que não
porque ela quer ficar em coimbra
quando falamos em locações e autoriza
quem emitir nick coimbra trabalhar
professor jogar vou para lisboa até não
falar em vocações que não 50 quilômetros
que se aplicava esse aplicava que se eu
porque sua cabeça ou se meu irmão porque
superação
eu não tava cinco minutos de carro nós
do hospital estava 50 em ser um problema
uma aposta agora em coimbra mas não quer
dizer que seja um pai que mais atento
com o outro nem implica na hora do amor
que assistirá na mão
desde que nós temos sim uma filha à mãe
que ela vai porque me quer
o jornal a mãe que está lá pra nós isso
tem que mudar necessidade
eu tenho 20 anos e tem dois meses o
momento é que um dia haja uma
oportunidade incrível e final como vir
aqui falar e não aproveitou na garra
mesmo conseguir porém mesmo se
ultrapassada em um outro medo é que um
dia meu livro também proponham que tira
a mesma participação que eu e minha
filha na vida de nossos filhos têm
vergonha de dizer na empresa onde
trabalha
querem ver o espetáculo qual é quer ir e
acompanhar a adaptação brasil
conseguimos a isto e por isso eu ia
explodir a tua voz paciência mensagem o
ensino superior ies e curiosas
conseguido tal solta e dois em cinemas
capazes de aguentar essa lei e são
também próxima a ela